hey Cyril
Padma Gretchen echo PETA new yes desde
red CAPRISA Aquin esto a red LED known
as Neto toast video display - eleda
probe a very good moment Slobodan simcha
after his audience even imagined
[Music]
sixteen years ago Slobodan see mesh
bought a dozen donkey his herd has since
grown to nearly 300 but hundreds of
donkey doesn't necessarily mean gallons
of donkey milk
unlike cows or goats donkeys produced
milk in very small quantities while
nursing their coal Oh Lozada says Evita
was a stroke
naima see rod McGregor great videos in
the tonic or new Skoda presenter so we
tried to make cheese from his donkey
milk but it turns out that process was
far from simple problems problem sirrah
you Tomer stolen Grigio named adobo no
Castorena choice losses does grow see
Allah America so he keeps his methods
secret hidden do go tram protests
cuadrado owed ResNet I ne'er saw a neo
dresnok problema quadruple udom
interracial Toya Oh No Kokomo Bouchard
autoshare would deny Reggie in I Scooby
me 10 Newton's Maria De Niro is nimona
predict a sea road maharaja black the
cheese goes for around $500 a pound and
it has a rich nutty and earthy flavor it
is known to be quite filling but just a
select few have tasted it you can only
get donkey cheese in Serbia in a post
ome cocoa a pro below Dionisio diatone
esto los note an Edison estos toy a
pause a blow in stone Eman a druggie
mess tema yo [ __ ] no Wabash Nostradamus
[Applause]
[Music]
windy nonsense a great on La Mesa Linda
you see cigarette oml Emily nel cuore so
daily Omni Oh circuit OD profession are
Latin fast a URI a ho value joseline OD
pasta dough finito acento chip on
possession little mint a super black a
solo for Salonika creation parishes
educated people effectively
[Music]
Yano me prob Rohini a Medeco AK West's
hasta que si chiama so villain do che
lavoro doll trek wearin Tommy
Seguin de un existed a la notte detente
queen de una fast antica calibre llamo
solo in Euro ding gradient del fin de oh
so no same ol a vegan oduroh
aqua sally quinn do proceed upon questo
movimento berlin army over Cagle ' dr.
voltage v modo de creer acoustic TV show
till i see me da da gyration fondo de
línea topo dkc meta basic Ariel solid
cuando una bella giornata puree a casa
el dinero de la casa temperature ambient
a non shell marchin air Kayla posso
Cleverley una casa que viene la grappa
solo dismissive Ament a a mono into Tosa
Ramona - inna de persona que los
Saffiano far a into toe el mundo West
apostasy tram and Adama dream cilia
Kamui pero el Centro no tradiciones de
familia que muchas any amo a canary
familiar non-resistant ultra-fast al
mundo come equation between tiga Emile
de Becque is a mercy vinegar model good
9-minute urine in the floor you know I
looked a another good to see my sister
is she was 50 ma 3 4 60 London amazing
to all the unbirthday not one pack food
that could say holiday I'm biased or not
she was a God he under Guinea my own
attorney sewage was given external disk
at all so no Guillermo Verdin II slipped
a Oki tally new United States or the
Syrians to our hinge of the state's
Fatima same highway near the tree
kali-yuga siento Yoshio technique to 9
to 16 or the key Knight c3 to our yoke
6th grader good hello casa su casa de
Jesus come oniy occur to me that this -
no day taking me neither fistula
juvinity like a technology so the
coconut you end up with Milo
you know karate ceremony total balance
the three des des animaux ripple
autonomous see ready for 1900 Kafka
wanna impact or an indicator to the
clinic on the day which it is imagine a
slow-roasted a Chile's met a more
equivalent series zero degree day and on
cinco to see also candle koto are giving
us or dodecane i are they carry such
ecstatic cinema not dicta clean or you
could utter suggesting that you can be
killed
[Music]
yeah Modesto bureau our CEO day pocono
llamando are as innocent Oh God
amicus class well she took our focus on
me it's like on Itoi mass again I'd so
you are anybody in skies me
[Music]
there's three things that are most
important to chefs first is flavor
second has flavor and third is flavor
flavor rules built on the Fertile former
lake bottom soil of northern Ohio the
chef's garden is a 300 acre family farm
that grows specialty produce for some of
the world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases we're working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farmers produce of all shapes and sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens
but the Jones family wasn't always the
chef's garden my parents have had some
very successful years in 1983 they had a
very devastating hailstorm and
ultimately the farm collapsed
we were Dell the new deck of cards and
found opportunity within a disaster
[Music]
we met a European influence chef
iris Balin to grow me varieties for
flavor Romy varieties without chemical I
want a zucchini bloom thought this lady
was absolutely crazy little do we know
she knew a heck of a lot more about it
than we did and that really opened our
eyes to another whole world out there
we hooked up with some really great
chefs early on folks like Danielle
Beaulieu and jean-georges Vongerichten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Rashard and
then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and in ritz-carlton chefs and for
seasoned chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture we're indebted
to those chefs that have given us the
privilege and the path to be able to
follow our dream of farming so it's that
symbiotic relationship of chef and
farmer working together for the greater
good and here we are 35 years later
still working to get better to the best
of our ability right now in this place I
think we're doing the right thing and I
think that trumps every other reason for
whatever you do in this life
it's red and pricey it's a critter and a
delicacies it's the creme de la creme of
seafood but this beloved summertime
favorite was once thought of as the poor
man's food say what it is said that in
the early 16th century as the first
pilgrims began to settle in bay areas of
america that the oceans overfloweth with
lobster no literally they overflow it
imagine a shore with a lobster wall 2
feet tall as one would expect the
settlers ate them up until like anything
eating 3 times a day they got sick of
them eventually deeming them the
cockroaches of the sea after that
lobsters were used as fertilizer fish
bait and ultimately prison food they
were fed so often to inmates that there
was even a law enacted to protect said
inmates from cruel and unusual lobster
punishment so then how did lobster
become the succulent delicacy we all
know and love fast forward to the
mid-1800s canned food became a thing as
did the railroad lobsters were canned
and shipped to middle America at the
same time middle Americans started
traveling to New England for fresh
lobster by the late 1880s prices began
to surge and by World War two lobsters
became the pricey specialty we've all
grown to enjoy
you